hey everybody yes as Tina mentioned 31
years ago today I was the greatest
achievement of my life to that moment I
was born and on my birthday today I'm
very excited to be sharing my
reflections on those 31 years with you
that's in general birthdays are a
special moment for reflection I'm and
I'm I'm extremely excited to be here to
do that we have a lot of ground to cover
in a few minutes and so I want to kind
of start off by saying I'm even though
I'm 31 years old I'm a fiduciary right
now for about 150 people have about 25
people working in our company that I
have to help make sure we we make
payroll and and then we have about 80
companies with one or two founders each
so somewhere around 120 founders that
we're supporting so some of the
responsibilities i feel like i have
sometimes we're more like a 51 year old
but I'm 31 and most people tell me I
look 21 so that this is this is this is
the kind of my story and of Rothenberg
ventures which is which is only three
years old I want to first say that I
can't really overstate how powerful and
important Stanford has been in in my
life it was a this is just it's not just
a cradle of innovation it's a it's it's
an incredible group of people that are
constantly building each other up here
and after and there's nothing that I
could have imagined that happened in the
stories i'm going to tell you after i
started stanford that can even possibly
be disaggregated from stanford and i'll
talk again about stanford it a little
bit but it's it's an incredible thing to
be here and be able to talk to you guys
the in particular that not just this the
students who I still work with some
people people that I've tommy's my route
was my roommate and Brandon ransom basis
things with me and and so you know we
still get to spend lot of time together
but a lot of the professors that were
here left left long and lasting
impressions in it and one reason why
it's so special to be here at etl is
because some of the professors that may
have the biggest impact on me like
nina and i'm not sure if Tom and Tom are
here oh hi Tom but this experience of
being able to be in this in this
environment of optimism and practicality
but also the the individual attention
that that was afforded is is it's just
it's impossible to overstate so so thank
you very much and then what I'm going to
try to do is I'm going to try to tell
you what I'll tell you then tell you
then tell you what I told you so we have
we have a few things cover I'm going to
start with context because I think it's
safe to say that the vast majority of
you have no idea who I am or why you
should care so we'll try to establish
some of that and then there's a there's
a little bit of risk and adversity and
everybody's story and I want to touch on
that it's without without touching on
that it's not it's it's not going to get
us there then I'm going to talk about
how we invest because we we invest
through networks and I think I think
that although we're not the only ones
who invest through networks perhaps our
approach will be interesting to you and
then and then I want to talk about our
actual company and its just sort of sort
of how we do some of the things we do
and so there's some we would you know
just just for the sake of making it easy
to remember we'll call that the people
and then the principles and the
processes and so will kind of talk about
some of those things in case there's
some you know some stories and takeaways
that we can we can leave you with then I
want to talk a little bit about strategy
in that particular section I've got some
things to say that I've never said
really to anybody outside of maybe some
people on the front row and it's a
sighting time to do that and then I'm
going to end with a little bit about
virtual reality and and and what what we
kind of see in the future and to that
point this this is a virtual reality
camera rig we do a lot of things in real
time it's not that big a deal that we're
kind of set that up as we go that
probably is a good metaphor for what we
do anyway there's five red dragon
cameras there that are stitched to this
is a custom-made rig and what we can do
and after we film with this is we can
stitch it into virtual reality
experiences like the ones that some of
you were just trying with the headsets
up here and to that point we'll have
those afterwards as well we have a lot
of these kinds of headsets so that you
can you actually
experience what VR is but but we'll kind
of end with that and so just to kind of
just but just to kind of jump in one of
the things that I'm really excited about
today's I did get a chance to think
about for a number of years what I might
want to share if I ever was on this
stage with people who are seeing there
because I sure I saw through about a
hundred of these in these seats and it
never and never got tired of it and and
so today I'm going to share some things
that I have never said publicly in part
because I believe that the way to do
that is with the Stanford community and
and and and there's some things here
that because our firm is so young
there's some things here that are
completely unproven so there will be a
little bit of a leap of faith here for
you guys because one of the debates that
that I sort of had with some people who
are you know really close to me about
what to share here is that I don't put a
lot of stock in what people say until
they've done it and on the other end of
the spectrum it's really important what
people are trying to do and what their
mission is and so I'm going to share
some things that it's safe to say we
haven't done yet with the with the hope
of inspiration and I hope you'll take
that leap of faith with me on that
because it to some extent it's it's
going to be a philosophy alright so for
context uh Who am I on Mike Rothenberg
hi guys i was born in texas that was
exciting and I you know the town
georgetown texas is you know safe to say
pretty much only known for having
varsity blues film there great movie and
and so what happened was is it pretty I
would say pretty normal town and and you
know not necessarily that exciting but
um I was really a fortunate to have
parents that cared a lot about education
and and so I my mom tells me I showed
interest in math and so that that was
provided and so that that was licensed
do tons of math problems so I did
probably Malcolm Gladwell's 10,000 hours
of math and that got me an invitation to
this institution which which which is
incredible when I came here I learned
that some of my favorite things about
math were actually pattern recognition
and problem solving the actual solving
of math is one manifestation of that but
here I learn
many more and in particular
entrepreneurship is an incredibly
exciting place to apply pattern
recognition and problem solving because
those are unsolvable problems you're
trying to figure out what you can build
that's meaningful in the future and you
have only your pattern recognition in
the past you have only your problem
solving to try to do it you'll never
completely do it the world is always
changing you're always going to be
dealing with people who are
unpredictable unsolvable and incredibly
exciting to work with and so that was a
that here it really in the equivalent of
this classroom is where I transition
fully from a math focus to an
entrepreneurship focus i went to the
school of engineering and and and and
that led to essentially where we are now
which is which is a lot of exciting
early-stage seed companies that we get
to work with every day on the order of
you know probably are someone in our
company is having a touch point with as
many as 100 companies a day they're all
trying to solve problems that haven't
been solved before and and so at
stanford one of the most impactful
things I did was I got to learn from
other people and and and in this
particular room got to you know help run
this the seminar series with some folks
here I got to start a company and and
then when I graduated there were a lot
of doors open for going to Stanford and
so I spent the next few years doing
things like management consulting at
Bain & Company and some time in private
equity at audax and so I had this resume
it got me into Harvard Business School
which is a great place to learn and
reflect and here we are I'm 28 years old
and I'm harvard business school it was
some phenomenal school now what so this
is where it gets interesting because a
lot of times we have an opportunity to
present ourselves to people and and and
it's very hard to do that except in a
resume fashion and so what I just gave
you was a resume and everybody is more
complicated than that and was it
whenever you think that somebody's just
a resume you definitely don't know them
there there is there is nobody that I
have encountered who is just a resume
and partly what this what this moment is
here is for me to try to explore some
things that
are harder to talk about than a resume
and at Harvard Business School like
Stanford it was an opportunity to
reflect and take stock of what was what
was going on it was you can kind of go
up a level and not be in the fray and
it's a wonderful opportunity to actually
think about you know what I was doing
because it's very hard to do that if you
don't pull out and think about it and so
when I was when I was 28 and in my first
year I went through a divorce and it was
incredibly hard on me personally and
okay and that's actually yeah that's a
learning moment because it's okay and
and and so what happened was there was a
you know is that there's there's an
intense personal thing I'm going through
and it was very hard on me and then on a
career front I didn't necessarily find
the the things I had been doing to be
fully fulfilling and it's it's if you
listen too much to people outside what
they'll say is that's a good job and
they mean that because there's a lot of
things about those jobs you know that I
mentioned things like them that are good
and so but what you have to decide is
what what are your values are they good
for you and are they really what you
should be pursuing and in a place like a
classroom is a good place to reflect on
that and so what was interesting is I
wasn't finding it to be very fulfilling
in my the jobs I done or the jobs i was
considering i had receipt i had worked
for and received an offer to go to a
hedge fund and live in a place that i
didn't necessarily care to live in but
be able to pay off student that
expediently that's always attractive so
if you have you know student debt and
you have these these jobs that other
people call good it's just very easy to
go down that path and there's really
nothing wrong with it but I really want
to kind of encourage people in the
spirit of entrepreneurship 22 to
question that though in terms of what
makes sure that it lines with your value
system and I had a value system of
mentorship my first company I started
here was a tutoring company had 25 of my
classmates I was coordinating to tutor
half of Palo Alto and it was it was
fulfilling I really enjoyed being on
that being
able to coach and mentor and train and I
wasn't really doing that in my
professional services jobs I really
cared about innovation I really cared
about things on the cutting edge I
wasn't really doing that in these jobs I
really cared about exploration
creativity and trying to help people at
scale and I wasn't really doing all the
things that I really want to do and so
what's really great about something
that's perceived to be public failure
such as you know a divorce or not being
satisfied your job or things is that it
does allow you it gives you permission
to reset when maybe you didn't give
yourself that permission because you're
already there you know you're already at
a place of public judging and so now you
say fine if that's going to happen then
let me just go ahead and and and figure
it out and one thing that I started
doing in earnest there that I haven't
stopped doing and hope to never stop
doing as I started asking everybody that
I I trusted really what they think and
being relentlessly open to feedback and
one interesting thing about feedback is
the first time you asked for it even
from somebody really trust is that they
will tiptoe if they're a good friend
they'll tiptoe because it's really hard
to tell somebody said go for the jugular
the very first time because you're not
really sure if they mean it people can't
give me feedback and you say yeah sure
you know your your shoe's untied and
they're like okay what else and then you
have to kind of tease it out and then
finally when they say it that when you
get to the thing that's like really may
be different from your world view at the
time but they say in a loving way they
care about you and they're right then
that cognitive dissonance has is the
moment where you need to actually
embrace that and that is hard to do but
you have to say thank you and so what I
learned to do over those few months is
to ask people in my life what what you
know for advice on all kinds of things
personal and professional and say thank
you and then really think about what
what mattered and resonated and one of
the things professionally I got a vise
from including people who are professors
including people i work from the past
and stuff is you should you you you you
have a good eye for entrepreneurs one of
the professors at Harvard said how many
of your friends that you were friends
with at Stanford are now entrepreneurs
and CEOs of venture-backed companies he
was trying to get and you know data to
help me help coach me I said more than
50 maybe a hundred he said that's not
very normal you know to have made
friends with people and then they did
that and then he said you know you may
be an entrepreneur talent scout you may
really like the kinds of things in
people that help them do that and and
they you know these are people who say
to my life and so he said you you should
you should at least try this if this is
what you love and switch you're
passionate about so I hadn't really
thought about being a venture capitalist
for one minute of my life and so until
that and and so then what I did was I
unfortunately didn't have really almost
any money and so that's a classic
entrepreneur problem is how do you
figure something out without resources
but with limited resources you never
have no resources and and so what i did
was i sublet my apartment so i didn't
have to pay rent and i spent pretty much
all of the money that I had on plane
tickets to go around and reconnect with
people in my life and it was it was a
dual purpose of being able to to bring
people back into my life and really
listen to them on the personal side and
also to to ask that some of the folks
that I that I had built relationships
with about this idea of starting a
venture fund and would they support it
and the very interesting thing is that
well the easy story to tell is that you
know after that 50 people invested five
million dollars and then I got to be in
a venture investor that that's factually
true but there's there's there's there's
a little more to it so it by the end of
the summer I I had to kind of just
enough money for two chances to try to
you know check and see you know on the
IP side if I could name the firm certain
things you know there's all these like
copyright protections and things and so
so I tried to things that I thought
looked like they could work and pay the
legal fees and stuff in and not neither
of them were they were both blocked and
so I ran out of money completely and and
I didn't have any more money for flights
for this that the other and so it turns
out that you can call the firm your name
and nobody can block you so Rothenberg
ventures is actually called Rothenberg
benchers because I ran out of money and
i did get advice from a couple mile
peace they said you're 28 you have no
venture experience why don't you you can
call it if you're Mike Rothenberg of
Rothenberg ventures people will listen
to you more than if you're Mike wrotham
or something else and also there's only
one of you so you might as well just own
that so I did and and so now i'm mike
robb Rothenberg ventures and then the
other thing is you know because I ran
out of money I had to start the
fun then because you know that's that's
really the main reason why it's like a
five-million-dollar funds because that's
the kind of ran out of time and money so
the the day I started the fun was the
day after I ran out of money so so
they're there i am now i have a
five-million-dollar seed funding as
Rothenberg ventures and i'm still a
second-year student at HBS and just as a
side note it is one of the worst pitches
in general you could possibly give to
say i'm going to be by myself i'm going
to be a full-time student I'd like to go
into a very complex difficult industry
that I know nothing about would you like
to give me five million dollars not a
good pitch in general but what people i
think we're investing in was was
actually the relationships and the
networks and and there's a lot more that
goes on just been making a pitch there's
there's kind of the 10 years before that
all right so that's that's that's that's
how I sort of got to the firm now the
other the other thing about having an
idea or a I guess a start-up I've always
run this more like I start up in a
venture firm and we still do I'll talk
about that too later but what what's
interesting is that you have to have
some sort of thesis an idea and so I
want to talk about the seed investing
landscape because while I was
fundraising and things over the summer I
was actually doing first person you know
primary research so another thing
Stanford afforded was opened doors to
and I was a student at the time member
because I was at a business school so
when you're a student and then you have
this network that this started here at
Stanford then people will talk to you
and it's it's just a wonderful pass and
so I got to ask questions that you know
really could have sounded quite stupid
if you know if I didn't feel the full
permission as a student and in fact that
the more stupid you feel asking the
question the more you need to ask that
question immediately don't ever hide
that that goes for everything so so what
happened was I I formed an opinion of
the seed landscape seed investing
landscape from an outsider perspective
because I had never actually done it and
so there although that's there's a lot
of problems with that meaning not having
that experience then then what you can
do is you can bridge that by talking to
experts and really listening and so
that's what i did and i'm sure i talked
to 500 people and and and i talked to
investors and people who are
venture-backed and people who invested
in me and and i began to form a thesis
so what I believe is really interesting
about the seed investing landscape and
I'm sure you've had some other people
talk about venture so i won't go into
the whole thing but it is now in for
five or ten years it is now way less
expensive to build a venture to build a
technology startup than ever before and
that is largely due to the variable
ization of most costs so where in the
past there could have been a tremendous
number of fixed costs to buy things like
server farms almost thanks to thanks to
folks like Amazon and so on there is
almost everything you do can be variable
eyes and and that's incredible that's
incredible that means you can run very
inexpensive tests from you know school
or dorm rooms or anywhere and then if
they start to work then at you can you
can scale you know up with your company
and that started to happen probably you
know eight or ten years ago and then and
then it's been it's been accelerating
and that does also mean that for a
couple million dollars for a company to
be able to actually have credibility to
grow into a large-scale syrup was not
really even a viable thing up until then
and so then then there was some early
pioneers in seed investing but but but
even that took a little bit and so it's
still only been in the last I would say
five years tops where people really
started to dive into seed investing and
that's been a just an explosion and and
seed companies and so on the seed
company side there are at least 10,000
if not 20 or 50 thousands different
start-up ideas you know people starting
things that you could as a seed investor
invest in and they're all around the
country and you know by definition
they're kind of undiscovered and that's
what it is and so this is a new problem
this is a problem that people were not
solving 10 years ago how do you parse
through 50,000 startups that aren't even
necessarily something that you can you
can see or find or touch without how do
you do that and then the other thing is
that as a seed investor you you have you
have less capital to deploy but by
definition and so now you have way less
capital then then then bigger VCS and
you have way more opportunities and
things you have to distill and I would
pause it there for this group that
that's a that's a relatively unsolved
problem the one thing I can say that
does that does not work is the is the
venture model that work that does work
if you have
you know five hundred million dollars
and a team of 25 people in a finite
world where you're the next
institutional investor because then you
can look at what's already been backed
and and that's a finite world so that
business model makes a lot of sense if
you're a big fund and if you're a small
fund trying to parse down fifty thousand
companies it actually makes no sense and
so there's a few different ways that you
could you could attack that I think and
one is hyper specialization and and that
could work and and the other one is
differentiation and there's not much of
that in the early seed for the reasons I
mentioned fortunately if you're really
trying to distill down how to how to
reach you know how to figure that out
that there is a pattern that great
founders do all have in common that is
actually that that's actionable and
visible and that is great founders are
amazing at getting support they are
amazing at getting support from people
who can really help them that is what
entrepreneurship is is getting support
outside of what you can currently
control and so because of that you can
you can observe who are good
entrepreneurs by who they're building
relationships with that is called a
network so the network is the only thing
that matters in seed it's the only thing
that matters in seed so how do you build
a network well there's there are a lot
of ways to do it but but one thing to
keep in mind is that it must be
authentic and it must be engaging and so
what and it must have alignment the
people who are in your network must also
benefit from it everyone must benefit
from it if they're not benefiting from
it it won't be rational for them to do
it and and and so you have to structure
it correctly and so one of the things
that that that we've done and since the
beginning is actually find the people
that we really want to build those
long-term networks with and people we
respect and people who could advise us
and advise our companies and all of
these things and actually see if they
will invest in us because because if
they won't invest and then they're not
really sold up obviously and so so
that's the that's the real test and the
beautiful thing about trying to find out
somebody want best is if they won't
invest they will often tell you why if
you if you if you really mean it if you
ask and mean it um so we have a hundred
and fifty investors and the vast
majority of them well over 100 our
founders and CEOs and execs at big tech
companies professors and accelerator
heads and venture capitals they are
experts and by doing
at then we kind of tap into the the
bigger network and individually these
folks have incredible networks and
collectively it's it's comprehensive and
so building that network is really
difficult but maintaining it is also
difficult and so I'm going to talk about
that in a little bit how do you maintain
a network like that once you have it and
so so as an investor you do have to make
choices and these do come through in our
case these come through our network in
pretty much every case and at the very
beginning when it was just me and and
and in 50 LPS and no reputation is
school then some of the first choices
that you make really matter a lot and
one of the most powerful signals that
you can have is who you personally know
has a track record of walking through
walls and so here at Stanford I I met a
few amazing people in fact one of the
investments that we invested in is
zenpayroll and josh reeves was here and
he also was led the seminar series of
number of years back and that was
amazing in fact we're also investors in
planetlab labs I believe that will will
be here soon so that's exciting and then
some of the first investments we had
were companies like revel systems and
inch up ease and Robin Hood all of which
are Stanford founders and and that you
have this sort of relationship now we do
I would say we've definitely gone beyond
just those kinds of networks but getting
started is really important and when
you're around people who are founding
companies like like those you're
incredibly good hands okay so now I want
to talk about people principles and
processes because this is a little bit
tactical and sometimes when you're
listening to somebody's stand up here
and tell you things you say what what
what can I do with it and what are my
takeaways and so I'd like to tell you
some of the things that we that we
experiment with one is what is here's
here's an interesting thing so when
you're when you're trying to decide if
you want to be an entrepreneur or if you
want to be an employee and it's it's a
it's kind of a classic challenge for
people who have entrepreneurial
instincts which is pretty much everybody
what's really interesting about that
choice is that entrepreneurs are so
driven about what they want to do that
they will actually make what appears to
be an irrational choice to do it
because they care so much and that's
because on an individual level when you
put years into something the outcome
ranges is to spread out you know it's a
very low probability even if you're a
great founder that you have some sort of
outrageous exit and then you may have
some sort of good outcome and it may be
the case that you know you take a low
salary for years and then never get any
equity either and so you've got these
three kind of outcomes that can happen
and it may be more rational if you could
have a really good expected value as
opposed to this kind of thing because a
lot of people that I know they're
building companies are doing it because
they're driven to do it and so the
financial trade-off is very strange
because you have this you have this like
crazy payoff system for one person and I
mean you know it's I suppose it's great
to make a billion dollars but like what
if you had you know way higher chance of
making you know 20 million I mean there
are sort of rational decisions that are
kind of messed up with entrepreneurship
and and so what happens is you end up
with the people who are the most
insanely passionate doing it because it
otherwise it doesn't make that much
sense and then when you're an employee
usually the trade-off you're given there
is you know we're going to tell you what
to do you know we're going to give you a
paycheck not a lot of upside but at
least you're going to get a regular
paycheck so your downside is you know
kind of protected from a cash flow
perspective and so that can become you
know kind of rational from a
practicality standpoint so now you have
these two extremes and at Rothenberg
ventures we do believe that there could
be a best of all worlds we sort of
generally believe that about everything
just because if you believe that then
you might as well check you can probably
try to figure out how that works and
let's just say that you could get the
expected value of an excellent group of
entrepreneurs but you could also build
something that you really cared about
maybe also with infrastructure and even
better if you had a lot of autonomy
remember even entrepreneurs don't aren't
do have bosses they have investors and
they have people sell their boards they
have other people so nobody doesn't have
a boss the question is who do you want
to who do you want to be you know
weighing in on the decisions that matter
to you and so we're we're building a
platform for entrepreneurs we're trying
to make it rational here for people who
want to build something that they're
very mission driven about to actually be
able to be in an environment where they
can build
that without a lot of red tape without a
lot of friction that can be very
mission-driven have the resources of a
firm the stability of a paycheck and the
expected value upside of a venture firm
because that's where you can have pooled
upside and and it is fairly unique if
not completely unique to our firm that
everybody at our firm who is works
full-time is eligible to receive Gary
upside and so what that does is that
means that everybody can actually be
working for the same thing and that's
also alignment with our LPS and our
founders and without that alignment it's
very it's very difficult to talk out of
both sides of your mouth you don't have
that alignment you don't have that
alignment and so that's that's what we
have and when we work together and pull
together then you can you can have an
expected value that is like a venture
firm and therefore can be more rational
for the / for the individual but you
could be working on something that's
really important to you so we are
working on so many different kinds of
things that but there's different people
working on them that you can imagine a
scenario where there's 20 different
projects 20 different leaders of them
and then when they need to flex into a
group of 20 they've got 19 more
entrepreneurs problem solvers who can
actually helped out in support so that
you can do crazy things and and one of
the crazy things we do is we we host
about 200 events a year we host about
200 events a year and and to do that you
have to tackle an insane number of
logistics and these do range from
anything from dinners and and and
speaker sessions not not unlike this to
puppy hours where we have puppies in
virtual reality and you know during the
cocktail hour to last Monday we rented
out AT&T Park and we had 500 mostly
founders come and you'll share share
small group sessions learn from
luminaries try 20 virtual reality demos
and hit baseballs from home plate and
and so we that ties back into before
about how do you engage a community you
actually have to be doing things that
people care about and have to do it on a
regular basis and if you if you are
working with high opportunity cost
people people who are building firms and
it's incredibly hard to do that have
very little free time and people
who are maybe a little further in their
career but they're still they still have
a lot of options in front of them then
it's really hard to get people to
excited to spend their most valuable
asset time unless it's it's it's amazing
and so you have to create amazing
opportunities and get people very
excited and and then you have to you
have to bring something else that's hard
to bring which is the future you have to
be able to show people something that
they haven't yet seen and so all of our
events we try to we try to show what we
believe the future could be and then we
have some say in that because we're
investing in the future and that's where
some of the promise I'll get to virtual
reality but that's that's where some of
that is so so then on the principle
basis I think that we have a couple of
principles that I want to touch on
before moving on one is we have a
culture of improv and it's the whole
culture it's actually not just like one
thing we do one of the best classes I
took a Stanford was was improv if you
haven't taken that please do it is so
insightful when it comes to business and
life and they teach you some very basic
things that you should never ever not do
one of them is say yes you can actually
always say yes you don't have to let
people manipulate you or make you do
something but you can find the good in
what anybody's saying because you should
first of all be dealing with people that
you have some modicum of trust for and
therefore there's a basis there when
people say something well even when you
want to say no you can you can find a
way to say yes and so what what what we
do is we will even we have an instinct
of saying no will say yes and we'll try
to find the truth first and then we'll
try to explore and it's wonderful to the
human ear to hear yes and it's really
grating to hear no so I encourage people
to define the yes and and everything the
other thing is with improv what's really
cool is that your you are having to
figure things out as you go if it
doesn't go perfect you're that's still
the world you're living in so you might
as well still adjust to that and move
forward and if you're you know if you're
talking and trying to share a very
intimate moment to like a lot of people
and some of these phone goes off you
could actually you know you could
actually not be happy about that or you
could say that's that happened now we're
gonna now we're going to make a lesson
out of it laughs together and move
forward and that's that's true with
almost everything and so so we believe
in an improv and we believe in
supporting each other it's very
rewarding to watch people support each
other that's why that's such a lesson in
empro
and when the attitude is how do we help
each other but everybody actually has
that attitude then you are way bigger
than the sum of your parts the other
thing for principles is structuring
things for alignment I'm you it's very
difficult if you find yourself in a
one-shot game so so in terms of game 3
where there is nothing afterwards
because then it's just a matter of how
do you divide up the pie whatever the
pie is whatever it is time money with it
you're trying to split up it's so so my
first piece of advice is don't be in a
one-shot game just don't be in that game
and and and secondly if you are in one
there's way more opportunities to turn
it into a multi shot game than you might
imagine so what you try to do is you try
to find a reason to do business again
with somebody and when I'm talking about
a business standpoint but this this this
should just apply overall but if you're
in a situation of something where you
believe it's a one-shot game then try to
find a way to make it a multi shot game
so we were in a position a couple weeks
ago where we got to there was a there's
a large financial organization that kind
of pulled out from supporting a cause it
was the global citizens festival in
Washington DC and they had a partner
that said they were no longer to help
out and there's only a few days notice
and because we are built on improv and
sort of just on Justin time principles
and things and and we have you know we
have we have friends there then they
said is there something you might be
able to help us out and so that's really
interesting because that could have been
a one-shot game or maybe we give some
financial support or some time and then
we're done or we could say yes actually
let's look at the whole thing maybe we
could film this in virtual reality maybe
we could you know help you out with that
but maybe our capabilities of hosting so
many events we could host you know one
of your like one of your events for one
piece of that maybe we could also bring
the virtual reality demos and people
could actually experience that and love
that and maybe your next event we could
be part of that too now we just turn
that into a relationship and a multi
shot game and it becomes in there
win-wins everywhere and that that's
actually really true so when you're
looking for alignment try to either be
in a multi shot game or create a multi
shot game out of it the other thing is
Oh everyone is rational that's a that
that's not necessarily what i believe
for a long time because it's too easy to
say because they're doing that that's
not rational actually everyone is an
incentive creature and we all are and
when you think somebody's acting
irrationally you don't yet understand
them be really careful what you do when
you don't know why it's what somebody's
doing is is is rational and then if you
have this general philosophy that
everybody's acting rationally for them
they're acting with their worldview
their incentives what they believe and
then then that allows you to be
empathetic and you try to understand
what is that and if you work hard to be
empathetic and really understand where
they're coming from what that
perspective is that will allow you to
find the win wins and create the multi
shot games and structure things for
success so we have a very strong focus
on trying to make sure that there are
win-wins everywhere and we're aligning
ourselves like that and that ties back
into building the network as well so I
already touched on the processes and one
of the big ones is people principles and
processes itself because everything we
do we want to identify who's doing that
what are the principles not necessarily
the rules that will do what our goals
and like what are we trying to follow
and then and then outlining what the
process is and process is almost like
coding it's like you do this and then
base it like if then than that then if
then is that and if you do if you do
things enough times like whether it's
hosting events or investing in companies
you should be able to create a process
that is general enough to work in
situations you're always going to use
judgment you're always can use people
but process is more fun than you think
especially if you come from a
engineering background to try to say
actually what are what is the world of
environments and then you see if people
can break your code and if an event
doesn't go the way you want it you your
code got broken how do you fix that if
you have if you have a team of
entrepreneurs the people thing is on
lockdown and then if you have if you
have principles that do things like be
nice to people and and give as much as
you can and say yes then that solves a
world of problems I would love to live
in a world where everybody's doing that
always so I'm going to end here before
QA with strategy and in virtual reality
and the strategy component it I'm gonna
I'm this is where i'm going to say some
things that I haven't said publicly I'm
testing this out and it won't be fully
baked but but I'll try so but the first
part strategy which which which is kind
of how we started doing this is it's
it's a blue ocean versus red ocean
strategy and for those of you don't know
I this came this particular thing came
about
in a Harvard Business School class where
we sat through a strategy class and you
know there's you know as 900 people per
class at Harvard Business School who
will largely do a lot of management
leadership and that's that's that's fair
because you you really kind of go there
to do that and they're pretty good at
selecting that and then and then people
really do that afterwards and so they
say okay you're going to be managing
things and leading and and so it turns
out that at least 95 person in the world
is a red ocean by that I mean a lot of
people know about that particular space
people are operating in it people are
competing with each other it makes sense
to focus on that because that's about or
at least ninety-five percent of people
and jobs and things are so what we do is
we spent probably ninety five percent of
our time and red oceans so they'll say
okay in a red ocean you have to
out-compete you've got to get your
processes down you know you really need
to you need to be fasting me a little
bit faster you be a little bit better a
little bit better recruiting you know
it's really hard to differentiate in a
red ocean because everybody understands
what's going on I think it's red ocean
because it's a bloodbath and so it's
like everybody knows and you want to get
the two percent got to beat the market
the markets doing this you got to go two
percent higher and that's that's
actually a fair characterization because
that's really the way most the world is
and so you know everybody's taking notes
and like trying to prepare for the Tesla
stuff and then like near the end of the
class they said we want to talk a little
bit about blue oceans so when you're in
a blue ocean it means that it's kind of
a new market it hasn't fully developed
and people are not yet sure where it's
going to go but everybody wins because
it's a blue ocean and everybody's
gathering the opportunities and now back
to red oceans rewind what did you just
say in a blue ocean everybody can win
until it becomes a red ocean that then
then the question then becomes how do I
get to a blue ocean stop this red ocean
nonsense there may not be very many of
them I should be focused on blue oceans
let everybody else deal with the red
oceans and what's so the reason why blue
oceans are hard is because people
haven't discovered them yet so you have
to be an explorer and you have to be on
the cutting edge of innovation and
things that are interesting and that's
why the future matters is because the
future is where the the future red
oceans is where the blue oceans are
today so you have to care about that to
find them and it's really important to
be in a blue ocean even if what you're
doing is you know joining a company you
know advising a company support your
whatever you need to be parts of blue
oceans and the way to find the blue
oceans is too
talk to other people trying to find the
blue oceans with a history of finding
them and one of the things that we do is
is we we have been experimenting with
virtual reality for two years we have
been investing in things like electronic
currency we have we're investing in
drones and space travel and these are
all potentially blue oceans now the blue
ocean start is blue ponds so it's
difficult to to see the growth rate that
a blue ocean that a blue pond can turn
into a blue lake and beautiful ocean
because if you're in a blue pond it
could actually dry up it could turn into
a blue lake and stay blue lake it could
turn into a blue lake and go back to a
blue pond and so it's not as easy saying
oh that's blue it may be blue but you
have to also be seeing the rate at which
it's growing but if you're there and
you're in a blue pond and you see it
rapidly turning into a blue lake and
then it turns into a blue ocean you may
have just found something great for for
your career and if you're in a red ocean
I really urge you to find just swim swim
swim to the blue pond it may seem like
it's smaller it may seem like it's not
as great but it is the proverbial be a
big fish there and try to figure out not
only where it's going but help build
where it's going it is that it is the
fish in the blue ponds that build the
blue lakes okay so here here's one of my
favorite points of the talk I saved it
for 45 minutes in not on purpose okay so
what what's what's um I'm going to tell
you my strategy it's a very debated this
a lot because it's not something you
really are taught to lead with is here's
what I'm planning to do because you know
you may not do it right you may not
float you know there's a lot of there's
a lot of ways that could go wrong so
it's better to tell people what you did
rather than what you're hoping to do but
here I'm really trying to also inspire
and I'm trying to get support we're
trying to build a network in a community
so if I am very forward about what we're
trying to do then maybe we'll attract
the kinds of investors to us the people
we can invest in people that we can have
on our team people who generally support
us if you are on board with that and so
here's our strategy step one if you want
the platform of entrepreneurs you do
have you do have to have essentially a
venture capital business model if you're
trying to get the pooled up side of an
entrepreneur and so in a knot in venture
capital because the seed stage as I
described before is really a nun saw
problem it's a it's really a blue pond
that turned into a blue lake but there's
a lot of people swimming around and
they're trying you know kind of red
ocean strategies in a blue and a blue
lake because that's the way that this is
that's a great place to be trying
something different so the only way you
definitely lose in that blue lake is if
you're doing the same thing that
everybody's doing in there in the red
ocean so as long as you're trying
something new you have a chance of
success and so we're in a blue lake
experimenting with the fact of building
a network to try to invest in the best
founders and seed companies there there
are and if you can pull that off then
you you should be able to continue to
build a network get get great great
founders great support and then continue
to complete the ecosystem by by working
with with them even after they finish as
advisors and investors and so on so so
step one try to try to build a some sort
of venture model but do it in a in a
blue in a blue blue ocean or blue lake
so that's that's that's the main thing
we do and that's the core of what we do
that's why if you've invested in 80
companies step two is give people a
reason to care and for us we created a
brand called River which is still the
same team and still all of us and it is
the brand for everything awesome yeah
yeah was that mean so so it it's it you
know awesome when you see it and you
care about awesome because it's awesome
and I'll give you some examples 200
events where we're engaging people
through things like virtual reality you
know renting out AT&T Park and having
people hit baseballs but but at all
along being able to interact with people
who are incredible and learning things
that's awesome and if you want to pick
you know a cause to support their then
help helping a shelter and being able to
play with puppies while you're there and
talking people is awesome and and being
able to watch great sporting events is
awesome and things like that so so
events are awesome we believe that
virtual reality is awesome so we create
experiences like that we have to have a
production studio it's the same team we
oh we also do you know investing we
create V our experiences and then we
share them we found that people think
that that's really awesome and and we do
have a racing team so
and the Global RallyCross lights
division we there's a there's a river
racing team that is us and it and it is
a brand for everything awesome that also
helps us engage our community keep the
dialogue going have have our experiences
and it turns out that both founders and
investors like being at racetracks and
writing and race cars and be having that
experience and it's awesome and it helps
us engage our community and that leads
us to step three which is the most
awesome of all philanthropy is really
awesome and the difficult thing about
philanthropy is that the value that it
can add is way bigger than anything else
and the economic ratio is the most off
so it's a cash drain and philanthropy is
really incredible because that is what
gets us the closest to health and life
and things that really matter and all
these other things we do can be can be
really important creating jobs is
important building products and services
make people's lives better is important
but actually having people get education
when they didn't have it is a step
function people get things like you know
clean water and food when they didn't
have it is awesome and people who have
you know qualities of life when they
didn't is awesome those are the step
functions most awesome those are the
same people who have the most trouble
paying for it now and there there's
something really interesting though
which is that a lot of the people that I
want to work with and people that I know
want to work with all care more about
those types of issues than all the other
things I've been talking about and
that's what makes it incredibly awesome
and there are win-wins and places that
you may not you know know and so if you
do think that someday your firm will
will be will be profitable and I don't
know why you're doing it if not then
don't wait 10-20 years to actually start
building off philanthropic capabilities
which some people are tempted to do
separate from their company do it now
and do it this doing this do it do it do
it authentically for what you can do so
that's what we believe that's a value
for us to give back you know in small
ways and bigger ways and in ways that we
have some differentiated advantage so we
are working with organisations
internationally and domestically to film
virtual reality experiences for
nonprofits to
to be able to create that empathy
machine and we will do a lot of that and
we will be telling stories not just
telling stories of places bringing it
here because ritual reality is that
medium but also taking it there and
showing other people what lives can be
like with education and and and and with
hard work and things like that and so
that's authentic to us because we can do
that now and my my very explicit dream
and I think it's shared by a lot people
on our team is that we can continue to
invest in in great companies we can
build and and and create awesome
experiences people care about that and
then we can actually work on the biggest
problems that change the world and
that's awesome that helps employee
retention that helps employee
recruitment it's does it this is not a
small thing this is the biggest thing
the best people in the world will only
work at a place like that once it exists
so if you have that capability you it's
not that it's not that you're don't
focus on the amount of money that you're
losing or spending spend what you can
lose what you can maximize that and make
sure that you are attracting the best
people in the world to do that so that's
the three-pronged approach I hope it
works I really hope it works and then
I'm just going to end with the quick
thing on virtual reality so that we knew
a few minutes of Q&A I took it took a
lot of time here so virtual reality is
really interesting because it's been
around for decades it's not a new
technology even as recent as you know
the 90s the matrix is a virtual reality
movie at about about virtual reality and
then there's been tons of experiments
and a lot of them have failed up until
now and that's because it's really hard
to create it's been really hard to
create a virtual reality experience
where as you moved your head your
goggles could render in real time so
it's about a tenth of a second if you
can't have your screen render as fast as
you can move your head at least process
it you get nauseous because your brain
says I must be concussed if I can't keep
up with what's going on here and it's
and it's and it's a jarring experience
the other thing is it's very the
computing power is very expensive and
then the screens have to be very high
quality and so it was really the mobile
it was really the mobile movement that
made as possible because that allowed
manufacturers you know such as says
Apple and Samsung and things to be able
to figure out how to build screens that
are there
that are really high quality at a very
affordable price and the CPU is the same
thing and so what happened really i
would say in 2014 for the first time is
that this mobile device that so many of
us have became a virtual reality machine
everyone has a virtual reality headset
who has a smart mobile phone you might
be a five dollar accessory away from
actually creating the experience but
this is a virtual reality headset you
all have them when people are wondering
about adoption for virtual reality you
have them and it's viral and when you
try a great experience you want to try
more great experiences and Samsung made
this super clear in probably about
October when they came out with their
their gear VR and said put with this
phone in here you have a virtual reality
headset and the experiences are
incredible and we had already been
investing in virtual reality for a
couple of years because it was a blue
pond and then it turned into a blue lake
and then when we saw that we said this
is going to be a blue ocean the internet
in 1995 is like virtual reality is today
it's not it's not fully there but it's
very obvious where it's going its
nascent but it will be ubiquitous we
hope that you tried virtual reality with
us we with with that excitement we
looked for where the center of the
ecosystem was for virtual reality we
realized there wasn't one we're
entrepreneurs we said we need to create
that so we built a program for virtual
reality companies to announce publicly
we were going to invest in at least 10
and put at least at least a million
dollars across the 10 if not more and
and we're going to do it in two months
and so then then we put out that signal
turns out there are hundreds of virtual
reality companies it has it you know the
the venture community up until that
point had really not considered this too
strongly so the vast majority were not
venture backed and we were able to get
hundreds of applications and pick 13
companies which which we created the
first we called it River because river
is awesome and and so then they just
graduated a few days ago and gave their
presentations actually there's a there's
a meetup called svv are that's near here
where you can it's a two-day meet up on
the eighteenth and nineteenth where you
can actually see those those demos and
you can see the presentations it's
really incredible and and you can see
where the world of virtual reality is
going but at Stanford in particular i
would i would encourage people to invest
in learning about this building this
this is this is the bluest lake I've
ever seen I would encourage you swim
that's it innovations a permutation
problem take great ideas and put them
together in new ways I started out as a
mathematician I don't think I've changed
try that try try them out test them
rapidly see what works and please don't
remember that execution is vastly more
important than ideas everybody has ideas
executions very hard and it's tangible
and you can see it swim to the blue
lakes try virtual reality and I'm ready
for questions please discuss the process
of finding the 14 lbs that you raised
five billion dollars the problem Cecily
how how did that process a little bit
like okay the question is can you please
describe how you found your first LPS
can you yeah the question is how do you
how did you find your first LPS it's
gotta get the the sound check right so
we're you know the audio that has some
test the same thank you so how do you
find it first cell piece actually this
is a great question for how you find a
start-up your first LPS anything that
you're trying to mobilize out of nothing
it's your last ten years of building
relationships it always is you know it's
it's just not smart for people to invest
in somebody that they don't ever know or
know anything about because then their
questions should always be shouldn't it
be the people who know you the best who
do that first answer is yes and if none
of the people who know you the best will
do that then you're not ready yet and
then you have to build those
relationships so my pitch may have taken
a summer but it really took ten years
tactical question don't worry rather for
ventures and what makes it unique and
one of the things that I thought was
very interesting as your philosophy of
not taking a board seat on any of your
companies could you talk about why you
do that yes well we will take board
seats in interims when the company's
really need us to so so the philosophy
is really more about being supportive of
the founders in every way we can but
also trying to align incentives and
trying to find the best overall outcome
so if you take yourself out of the
equation and you're investing in a
company then the real question becomes
who is the right board member of course
you need governance
maybe not necessarily the first year or
so when when everything so hectic and
crazy that you have to mobilize it's not
that you have to form a board
immediately or even though i'd recommend
that but as soon as you start taking on
people's capital from the outside you
are fiduciary and when you do that and
then it's it's pretty smart to have
great advice and governance and so at
that point the question is who are the
best board members in the world for for
this startup and how do I get them to do
that and it is people who have
experience in particular in that
industry so you get kind of your
investor for free we're venture
capitalist we're going to help you
anyway we're the most aligned with you
we gave you a bunch of money we care a
lot and we built up an ecosystem to help
you so you get us for free so why put us
on your board we're probably not the
right ones and there's almost certainly
many people in our network who are
better at advising us who've built this
before and so that's how we approach
that the problem is who's the right
person it's not usually us and and it
could be if if the company so is so
smaller in an interim period where they
really need that advice and in that case
we'll help them out in the interim until
we find somebody better the interest in
this question is probably another
lecture but we talked about the last 10
years you can a thumbnail of what the
world looks like to you in 10 years time
okay so the question is what what what
do I think the world's may look like in
10 years I'm a process person so I kind
of say how well approach it we don't
really spend a lot of time actually
worried about that because we're worried
about how to be there at the right place
in the ten years and so we're kind of
working on our on our stroke instead of
like trying to you know look at crystal
balls and so what happens is what is
guaranteed is that there will be a lot
of innovation and people will create all
kinds of crazy things and it will come
out of nowhere and that's why the blue
oceans come out because nobody saw them
coming from the blue ponds and so what
we'll do is we'll we will invest in the
blue ponds and then more in the blue
lakes and even warn the blue oceans
until they turn red and so as that
happens we want to want to be there so
to answer your question though more
directly virtual reality is such a big
deal because this will take at least a
decade probably way longer to play out
and it is there in terms of hardware
software and content it's it's it's it's
half it's it's really half amazing and
half imagination and so when you're
trying you got to kind of see where
that's going that's going to take a
while and it's really interesting
so I do see that the experiences and how
we helped me engage with almost
everything around us will be affected by
that everything every industry so that's
why that's so interesting and then you
know we'll space travel mat matter yeah
I mean people will hop on planet like do
that occasionally at a high-end allah
steps there's all these other things
that like kind of matter you can see
what we're investing in in our portfolio
to see the clues on what we think is
going to matter in a few years but
people will still be people there will
still be massive amounts of problems
we're going to philanthropy more than
ever and we hope that there are as many
companies as possible please let this be
a call to action that actually
simultaneously take care of profit
models try to create something
interesting and awesome for people
engage with and then use all of that
community and support to to actually
work on philanthropy in a for-profit
situation because that with the same
team so that you can take all the
learnings you have in the for-profit
sector pay people like a for-profit
sector solve profit solve problems like
it's nonprofit I hope that I hope that
they're a lot of companies that are
doing that in the future we don't know
that that's going to be the case yet but
maybe this talk will have encouraged
somebody to do that
you